>> Greg: AS TRUMP UNLEASHED
TWEETS THAT TRIGGER THE MEDIA
MELTDOWN, AND ANTIQUE THE
DISCIPLE ATTACKED AND
IMMIGRATION CENTER.
THE PRESS WAS BUSY OBSESSING
ABOUT THE SQUAD SWORD GARGLED
MINIMAL COVERAGE.
EASY TO SEE
WHY.
THE MAN USED TO SAY IN RHETORIC
HE AND IDENTIFIED AS PART OF
ANTIFA.
IT'S HARD FOR CNN TO CONDEMN
SOMETHING WHEN THE TERRORIST IS
PARROTING SOMETHING YOU SAY.
WHEN YOU'RE COMPARING I.C.E.
AGENTS TO NAZIS, HOW CAN YOU
TRASH THE FAN OF YOUR WORK.
HOW CAN YOU EXPOSE A HOAX WHEN
HE BEEN SELLING THE HOAX FOR
YEARS.
WE SHOULDN'T DO WITH THE MEDIA
LIKES TO DO TO YOU, WHEN A
RACIST COMMITS AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE, THEY WILL EXPAND TO
INCLUDE ANYONE RELATED MEETING
IF A VIOLENT RACIST LIKES FRIES
AND YOU LIKE FRIES, YOU'RE
RACIST AND PROBABLY OVERWEIGHT.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THIS DEAD
GUY DOESN'T REFLECT ALL
DEMOCRATS.
HE WAS JUST ANOTHER NUT WHO
WANTED TO BECOME WHAT THE MEDIA
GLORIFIES.
AN AVENGING ANGEL.
THE RESULTS, MILK SHAKES, MOBS,
MAYHEM.
PUNCH A NAZI'S PUNCH ANYONE.
THIS GUY DIDN'T DIE FOR A CAUSE.
HE DIED TO IMPRESS A BUNCH OF
LOSERS.
HE DIED HOPING CNN WILL SAY HIS
HEART WAS IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
WHO KNOWS, MAYBE THEY WILL.
CAPRI, I ALWAYS SAY THAT BOTH
SIDES HAVE CRAZIES.
CRAZY SHOULD NOT DEFINE YOUR
SIDE WHICH IS WHY IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THAT SIDE TO
POLICE THEIR OWN CRAZY.
I POLICE MY CRAZY.
>> Capri: THERE'S PLENTY OF
CRAZIES TO GO AROUND BOTH SIDES.
FOR ME, IT'S ALL ABOUT
CONSISTENCY.
YOU BRING UP THE FACT THAT THE
MEDIA DID NOT COVER IT IN A WAY,
SAYING THIS PERSON ECHOED AOC'S
REMARKS ARE SOMEHOW THEY'VE BEEN
-- THE SENTIMENTS HAVE BEEN
MANIFESTED IN THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE.
WHICH WE SEE ALL THE TIME.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, IF SOMEONE
APPROPRIATES MAGA.
THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN, LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE GUY IN THE VAN AS
WELL, LIVING IN A VAN BY THE
RIVER, BERNIE SUPPORTER WHO SHOT
UP THE CONGRESSIONAL BASEBALL
TEAM PRACTICE.
THERE IS ENOUGH TO GO AROUND.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
THEY ARE ALL CRAZIES AND IF WERE
GOING -- WE NEED TO DO IT
CONSISTENTLY.
MAYBE THIS PERSON WAS INFLUENCED
BY AOC AND NEEDS TO BE TOLD IN
THE SAME MANNER AS SOMEONE WHO
MAY HAVE SOMEHOW BEEN MOTIVATED
TO SEND BOMBS TO CNN, LIKE THE
CRAZY GUY, THE OTHER CRAZY GUY.
>> Greg: I WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE GUY IN MIAMI WITH ALL THE
STICKERS.
>> Capri: BE CONSISTENT.
>> Greg: THANKFULLY, NOTHING
TO CHANGE THE CRAZY PEOPLE.
>> Dana: REMEMBER THE
PITTSBURGH SYNAGOGUE SHOOTING,
SO HORRIBLE AND IMMEDIATELY THAT
WAS BLAMED ON TRUMP.
THEN IT TURNED OUT HE WAS
AGAINST TRUMP.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Dana: IT'S A FRUSTRATING
THING BUT I DON'T LIKE THE WHOLE
-- REMEMBER THE SARAH PALIN
CROSS HAIRS THING AND THEY BLAME
THAT ON HER TOO?
THIS REALLY DID NOT GET MUCH
ATTENTION, SOMEONE TRYING TO
ATTACK A GOVERNMENT BUILDING.
>> Greg: HE DIED IN A
CONFRONTATION WITH THE COPS.
>> Jesse: THAT MEDIA DOES NOT
REPORT THE NEWS.
THEY REPORT THE NARRATIVE IN ONE
OF THE BIG NARRATIVES OUT THERE
--
THERE --
>> Greg: THAT IS A QUOTE ON A
COFFEE MUG.
>> Jesse: THE BIGGEST
NARRATIVE OUT THERE IS THAT THE
RIGHT IS VIOLENT IN THE LEFT IS
NOT.
SO EVEN WHEN SOME GUY, LET'S SAY
SMIRKS AT SOMEBODY, THAT'S
CONSIDERED A VIOLENT ACT.
WHEN THERE'S AN ACTUAL VIOLENT
ACT, IT'S NOT COVERED.
TWO OF THE THREE NETWORKS DIDN'T
COVER THE STORY THAN ALL THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA NEVER REPORTED
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN ANTIFA
AND THE ATTACK.
THEY WILL FRAME, AS DANA SAID,
CONSERVATIVES.
REMEMBER THE AURORA, COLORADO,
SHOOTING.
"ABC NEWS" SAID IT WAS IT TEA
PARTY SUPPORTER AND THE GUYS
NAME WRONG AND IT WASN'T THAT
GUY.
YOU HAVE ECOTERRORIST, BLACK
LIVES MATTER WRITERS, YOU HAVE
ANTIFA, WTO, ANARCHISTS, ALL
THESE PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
COMMITTING VIOLENT ACTS AND
THEIR NEVER TREATED THE SAME
WAY.
THEY'RE ALWAYS EXCUSED AS SOCIAL
JUSTICE CRUSADERS OR VICTIMS OF
CAPITALISM.
THEY ARE NEVER TREATED THE WAY
THE RIGHT WING VIOLENT PEOPLE
ARE.
PERMISSION TO MAKE A SOCIAL
EXPERIMENT SUGGESTION.
>> Greg: I AM SCARED.
>> Jesse: PUT A MAGA HAT ON
AND WALKED DOWN TO GREENWICH
VILLAGE, DO A FEW LAPS AROUND
THE BLOCK.
PUT AN OBAMA HOPE AND CHANGE
T-SHIRT ON AND GO TO THE FLORIDA
PANHANDLE.
SEE WHO IS VERBALLY AND
PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED AND SEEMS
NOT.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO PUT ON
MY MARIANNE WILLIAMSON CHERT.
TO JESSE'S POINT, THERE IS WEIRD
HOW RIGHTEOUS VIOLENCE IS
ROMANTICIZED, I WOULD SAY IN
ACADEMIA.
THE SLA -- CHARLES MANSON WAS
ROMANTICIZED.
THE BOSTON BOMBER ON THE FRONT
COVER OF ROLLING STONE.
WE DON'T ROMANTICIZE OUR CRAZY.
>> Dagen: THERE IS THE
JUSTIFICATION OF VIOLENCE OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IN THIS CRAZY
POLITICAL AGE BY THE LEFT
WING NUTS.
WHAT BOTHERS ME IS IT'S THE SAME
THING THAT RAPE VICTIMS HAVE
HEARD FOR DECADES AND DECADES,
THAT YOU BROUGHT IT ON YOURSELF.
YOU ASKED FOR IT.
WE NEED TO FIGHT BACK AND SO WE
WILL ATTACK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHAT IS
ACCEPTABLE TO THE LEFT?
IS IT TIRE IRONS?
PUNCHING SOMEONE IN THE FACE?
CONCUSSIONS?
IS IT RAPE OR MURDER?
WITH THIS ANTIFA GUY, 24 HOURS,
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK NEWS CYCLE OF
SNEERING, SNORTING, AND
SCREAMING TO THE HIGH HEAVENS
ABOUT HOW CONSERVATIVES CALLED
IT ABOUT HOW THIS IS THE FAULT
OF THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
WE ALL KNOW THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
IT WOULD GO.